look i came in my office this morning  and beijing is trying out the new chair  i tried to pet her but she was like ah  she kept like moving her head around  yeah i'm talking about you princess  you're so pretty  you're so pretty  uh oh  here comes trouble  here comes trouble  what's up pookie you were mad because  the attention wasn't on you oh  rumble in the office chair  say  oh uh oh pookie she's mad  she's like oh okay i don't know  oh my goodness  oh please don't mean to that baby she  just wants to see what's going on  oh  why are you so mean beijing  she wants to be your little friend she's  like yeah she doesn't know like that  baby  that's okay poke  yeah  what do you got to say about that  yeah fishing yelled at you